l'algérie va traiter tous les malades
atteints du cours navires us à la
chloroquine son utilisation en algérie a
été a confirmé mardi dernier par le
ministre algérien de la santé le dernier
bilan de la contamination aux convives
19 en algérie fait état à 2 35 décès 584
cas confirmés à face aux faiblesses du
système de santé les initiatives
citoyennes pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus
elles se multiplient grâce aux appels
via les réseaux sociaux à des bénévoles
d'associations locales font du porte à
porte dans les rues d'alger elle pour
offrir leur aide aux plus démunis et aux
personnes âgées
la première chose que nous avons faite a
été d'acheter cet appareil pour prendre
la température et ce masque médical que
nous portons lorsque nous travaillons
avec des manifestants dans la rue pour
fournir une aide humanitaire aux
personnes malades et âgées pour qui le
co vite 19 représente un grand danger
nous leur avons dit de rester chez elles
que nous viendrons les et des
solidarités
nous allons à la rencontre des personnes
qui ne peuvent pas quitter leur domicile
des personnes âgées qui ne peuvent pas
aller à la banque pour retirer de
l'argent
nous leur disons de rester chez eux pour
éviter d'être infecté par la maladie que
nous viendrons vers eux et leur
apporterons l'aide alimentaire adéquat
pour une période de deux semaines et que
lorsqu'ils ont besoin de quoi que ce
soit qu'il nous contacte à l'association
nous leur enverrons des jeunes
volontaires pour acheter tout ce dont
ils ont besoin
en portant des protections afin qu'ils
ne soient pas non plus infectés par la
maladie et l'alcool
c'est une première étape si dieu le veut
il y aura d'autres initiatives et nous
remercions les bienfaiteurs qui ont
contribué à fournir ce convoi médicales
c'est un devoir que nous devons faire et
non privilège où ils faveur il est de
notre devoir de nous tenir aux côtés de
notre pays en crise et année